Those little boys and girls are counting on us
all of this is for the children for the children
for the children
The devil's in the details bev
that's not the only place he is
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision mephisto video there have been a lot
of mephisto easter eggs the devil is in the
details and that's not the only place that he is
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'm doing videos
for all the Wandavision episodes and we're doing a
disney plus giveaway for memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite mephisto reference or devil reference
on the video careful for spoilers if you have
not seen any of the episodes yet we'll be talking
about everything that's happened so far and
some really old easter eggs from back in marvel
phase one referencing mephisto there have been
many mephisto easter eggs on Wandavision so far
in the mcu in general even in some of the other
marvel phase four series like falcon and winter
soldier and the loki trailer the reason why
mephisto is getting so much attention right
now on Wandavision is because he's such a big part
of her backstory with the twin children billy and
tommy wicked in speed and they're doing that story
on the show mephisto is also a big marvel villain
that both scarlet witch and doctor strange share
in common and Wandavision will cross over with
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness in addition
to spider-man 3 and a bunch of other stuff so
everyone's just wondering if mephisto the actual
character will show up during Wandavision so we'll
start with the Wandavision mephisto easter eggs
then i'll talk about the older ones and some of
the ones in the other marvel phase four trailer
videos like falcon winter soldier and loki because
for instance the older marvel phase one references
were for a mephisto storyline that kevin feige
swerved on and wound up changing their plans for
mephisto and the mcu just in general changed a
long time ago but they're still really cool easter
eggs the first big one on Wandavision is actually
the iron man stark industries toastmaster 2000
commercial if you re-watch the commercial and you
flip the frame upside down you notice on the first
toaster the regular one the symbol is actually the
numbers 6 6 6 the mark of the beast the mark of
the devil then during Wandavision episode 2 that's
where they really crank up the references akita
harkness keeps referring to her mystery husband
ralph like he's a terrible person and she can't
stand him the name ralph also translates to famous
wolf in norse mythology similar to the language
the asgardians thor normally speaks ralph is
also the name of one of the villain characters
during lord of the flies his character represents
evil during lord of the flies a group of children
get marooned on a remote island and have to
survive cut off from the regular world during
Wandavision everyone inside the alternate reality
the tv-based reality are cut off from the normal
mcu universe and they keep talking about children
chanting in unison about children when
you notice that there are no children
anywhere in the town until scarlet witch gets
pregnant at the end of the episode those little
boys and girls are counting on us all of this is
for the children for the children for the children
i want to thank you all for coming out to
support west view elementary for the children
totally not creepy when they all chant in unison
multiple times during the episode like that
but she also tells scarlet witch to bring ralph
out of the magic box the one with the graphic of
the infinity stone on it that's meant to be a
representation of vision's origin story in the
box that ultron created him in as if agatha
harkness is implying that the reason why we
haven't seen ralph yet she only just mentions him
and he's off screen somewhere is because he can't
enter this alternate dimension yet and agatha
harkness is trying to manipulate scarlet witch
into helping ralph mephisto nightmare whoever he
might wind up being enter the main mcu reality and
they're using this alternate reality scenario to
do that also the bunny that agatha the hardness
brings with her during the beginning of the
episode and then you later see pop-up during
the magic show she gives it to scarlet witch she
says his name is senor scratchy nicholas scratch
is the name of mephisto the devil uses during
the short story the devil and daniel webster
which bears some similarities to what's happening
during the Wandavision series you may remember
the simpsons did a parody of this a long time
ago during treehouse of horror it was the homer
simpsons soul donut episode it plays out like
the original devil vs daniel webster storyline
during that storyline the devil comes to a
person named mr stone and gives him seven years
of prosperity in exchange for his soul and when he
comes back to collect stone bargains for an extra
three years extension after the three years the
devil comes back to collect finally and refuses
to get more extensions but daniel webster comes
along and offers to help mr stone get out of the
contract by fighting the devil in court through
a lot of speechifying and legal magic work daniel
webster winds up beating the devil in court using
a little bit of trickery on Wandavision this could
just be a metaphor for the way scarlet witch was
able to create this alternate reality to give her
this time of prosperity with vision bring him
back to life exactly the way she remembers him
have the family she always wanted making a deal
with the devil so to speak to make this happen
and then later maybe she tries to get out of the
deal and keep vision in her twin children but i'm
only expecting some surface level references
and similarities it's not meant to be an exact
copy of that storyline but the fact that agatha
harkness herself keeps making direct references
to the devil the devil is in the details and
that's not the only place he is also implies
that she's somehow connected to that entity and
also when dottie said that the devil is in the
details you may not remember if you didn't watch
the show but this actress also played a demon on
buffy the vampire slayer just another connection
to mephisto the devil but also another callback
to the bunny she was afraid of bunnies on that tv
show so i think that's just meant to be a really
meta reference to all these different things
including mephisto the other big marvel phase
4 mephisto easter eggs in the loki trailer are in
the stained glass window there's this depiction of
the devil in this church that is made to look
just like comic book mephisto page to screen
it could just be more evidence that he exists in
the mcu because it seems like the time variance
authority this organization that loki is working
with here just has a broader understanding of
reality in general in the multiverse and i think
a lot of us are also expecting to see teasers for
the main villain of doctor strange two during
Wandavision and who better than someone like
mephisto or nightmare nightmare was the previously
rumored villain of doctor strange too when scott
derrickson was still directing the movie now that
sam raimi is directing it they could have changed
that just a little bit nightmare's powers are
just a little bit different from mephisto but
you could also explain how nightmare could be
the person they're referring to when they keep
talking about ralph and the devil but there's
also another easter egg during the falcon and
winter soldier episodes it doesn't show up in the
trailer footage it actually shows up in footage
of them filming for scenes that are going to take
place in madrid which is a big x-men location and
obviously scarlet witch big connection to the
x-men characters you have this biker gang here
that eventually falcon and winter soldier are
going to fight with the symbol on the backs of
all their jackets is the face of the devil just
another reference to mephisto even though falcon
and winter soldier is going to be more straight
up action mcu series like a more traditional big
marvel comic book event like you would expect most
of the stuff they're going for on that series is
the weapons plus the super soldier program
that kind of leads to weapon x so it's also
tied to future x-men stuff wolverine weapon x so
even though falcon and winter soldier themselves
aren't that related to x-men characters don't
cross over with them that much during the comics
they are still using that series to set up big
future marvel phase 4 stuff just like Wandavision
is helping set up mutants in x-men inside the mcu
i'll talk more about that stuff when we get those
falcon and winter soldier episodes later this
year in march but the really cool older marvel
phase one mephisto easter egg that goes back
to the first avengers movie is actually during
this scene where nick fury is coming to recruit
captain america for the avengers team when he's
pounding the bag remember we saw that during the
post-credits scene from the first captain america
movie you here with a mission sir i am trying
to get me back in the world trying to save it
hydra's secret weapon he shows up and gives him
a file on the infinity stones in the tesseract
and the file also mentions mephisto directly by
name so the text if you can't read it here says
as shield wish to harness the power of
the tesseract mephisto was enlisted to
aid them in their efforts studying the cube
mephisto proposed that the tesseract could be
as powerful as the infinity stones so this is
a huge revelation originally they had intended
for mephisto to actually be working with shield
on the dl them literally making a deal with the
devil to learn more about the infinity stones
so it sounds like kevin feige had mephisto just
being a huge part of the infinity saga and the
infinity gauntlet storyline because he is a big
character during the comic book version of the
infinity gauntlet storyline but as you saw play
out during marvel phase 2 eventually marvel
phase 3 over time either because of the china
devil issue or some other reasons they pivoted
away from the mephisto character and changed
the storyline and now if you re-watch the first
avengers movie in this scene on disney plus for
example they've digitally removed mephisto's name
from this dossier so they've kind of retconned
this out but now it just seems like they brought
him back in during marvel phase four in some way
at least in some form there will continue to be
more devil in mephisto references during future
Wandavision episodes as part of her storyline
with her children so i'll just point them out
as we see them i'll probably have to do another
big mephisto easter egg video after episode 9
just because there's going to be so much stuff
happening my full Wandavision episode 3 video
is going to post friday just like normal so make
sure you have alerts turned on for my channel so
you don't miss that and if you didn't see it
paul bettany dropped this huge bomb recently
he just said that there was an avengers endgame
post-credits scene that they wound up having to
delete that completely set up what was happening
on the Wandavision series you can click here to
watch that post-credits scene and you can click
here for all my other Wandavision episode 1 in
episode 2 videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!